und damit herzlich willkommen zu einer
weiteren Folge dhdl Produkte testen
eines eurer lieblingsformate hinter mir
aufgereiht fünf Produkte insgesamt
testen wir heute sieben zwei davon sogar
im Außeneinsatz und wie immer vom
geringsten bis zum teuersten funding
also bleibt bis zum Schluss dran wenn
ihr erfahren wollt wer am meisten Kohle
eingesetzt hat Produkt Nummer 1 leider
gar keine Kohle eingesackt angefragt
waren 200.000 € für 20 %. was sind 4
Wert von einer Millionen Euro ergeben
hätte bekommen hat der Gründer leider
keinen Deal und wir schauen ob das
gerechtfertig war oder nicht das handelt
sich um ein e-trike sowas wie ein
E-Scooter nur mit drei Rollen und ein
paar mehr Funktionen der Gründer war
ziemlich überzeugt von seiner Idee und
hat so ein bisschen so dargestellt als
wäre es eine wirklich neue Art von A
nach B zu reisen ob das aber tatsächlich
so ist und ob der Preis von 7.900 €
gerechtfertigt ist schauen wir uns jetzt
an wir haben gerade schon mit dem
Gründer gesprochen unheimlich viel
Gedanke Energie und Erfindergeist
eingeflossen in dieses Ding und genauso
sieht das auch aus wir haben hier zwei
Pedalen links und rechts hydraulische
Bremsen links und rechts zwei Akkus
links und rechts in Deutschland
hergestellt in Deutschland entwickelt
also es fühlt sich richtig stabil an und
wir sind hier mit einem der allerersten
Geräte unterwegs
komisch an
[Musik]
macht unheimlich viel Spaß ist es zu
teuer ja für die meisten wahrscheinlich
schon erfüllt es einen richtigen Zweck
wahrscheinlich nein löst es irgendein
anderes Fortbewegungsmittel ab
vermutlich auch nein aber es macht Spaß
und das ist vor allem für die Leute gut
die sich nicht der Gefahr des
Motorradfahrens aussetzen wollen für
mich ein perfektes mittleres Produkt es
ist einfach ein bisschen zu teuer auf
der anderen Seite in Deutschland
produziert es liegt genau in der Mitte
Spaß gemacht hat auf jeden Fall
und nach dieser sportlichen Aktivität
fühle ich mich etwas verspannt womit wir
zu Produkt zwei triggerdinger kommen
angefragt waren 120.000 Euro für zehn
Prozent was in vielen Wert von 1,2
Millionen Euro gemacht hätte bekommen
hat der Gründer seine 120.000 Euro aber
für 23 Prozent was sind Firmenwert von
ungefähr 521
000 € macht und dieses von den kamen im
Kooperation von Ralf Dümmel und Carsten
Maschmeyer ziel dieser Produkte soll es
sein eine Behandlung die man eigentlich
nur durch geschulte Therapeuten bekommt
selber zu Hause durchführen zu können
nachdem der Gründer sind ziemlich
krassen Unfall auf dem Skateboard hatte
hat er gemerkt dass punktuelles drücken
am gewissen Stellen seine Schmerzen
lindert und ihm dabei hilft wieder
besser zu recovern unter dafür genau
diese Produkte hier auf den Markt
gebracht anders als bei dem Produkten
von blackroll beispielsweise bei denen
man großflächig bestimmte Regionen vom
Körper behandelt ist das hier wirklich
für einzelne Triggerpunkte gedacht also
die verschiedenen Artikel für
verschiedene Anwendungsbereiche in
verschiedenen Stärken für einzelne
Punkte und bevor wir zum wirklichen Test
kommen
sich kurz ein Gefühl äußern an einigen
Produkten sind an manchen Stellen
irgendwelche kleinen Verunreinigungen
oder Produktion sehr Fehler will ich
nicht sagen aber es sieht nicht 100%
verarbeitet aus es wirkt aber irgendwie
entweder benutzt oder als wäre es jetzt
nicht 100% Produktionsqualität zum
Beispiel Luisa Stelle ist zwar jetzt
nichts dass die Funktionalität wirklich
beeinträchtigt aber bei dem Preis von
bis zu 40 € und dem Gefühl von Medizin
für zu Hause eine medizinischen Produkt
erwartet man so ein bisschen was anderes
jetzt aber zum Test auf dem Verpackungen
selber finden wir einen how to guide das
schauen wir uns mal an und tatsächlich
bin ich wirklich gespannt weil ich immer
mal wieder Probleme mit dem Rücken habe
zu wenig Sport zu viel am Rechner ich
wähle mein Produkt aus wenn du die
Punkte gefunden hast kannst Du langsam
deine Beine anwinkeln das wird dein
Becken kippen und den Druck auf den
Punkt weil ich ja schon begeistert und
blackroll Benutzer bin kann ich mir
vorstellen dass das hier ziemlich krass
wird also das ist wirklich krasse
punktuelle Belastung
ist relativ einfach zu fühlen im Prinzip
da wo man Schmerzen hat wo eine
standardverspannung ist legt man es hin
jetzt langsam runter was fällt schwer
dabei zu reden
weil man sich automatisch anspannt in
dem Moment wo man redet
[Musik]
diese Sounds dir gerade gehört habt
waren echt ich bin also im Zweifelsfall
der perfekte Kunde für triggerdinger auf
den ersten Blick hat sich das richtig
gut angefühlt und es gibt ja noch eine
Menge weitere Produkte deswegen nehme
ich alle Produkte über die nächsten 7
Tage unter die Lupe und das Ergebnis und
meinen Bewertung seht ihr später Produkt
Nummer drei eins der Produkte auf die
ich mich am meisten gefreut habe in
dieser Folge nennt sich Flasher und ist
die Lösung für ein Problem dass jeder
Fahrradfahrer vor allem in der Stadt
sehr gut kennt ziemlich cooles packaging
muss ich schon sagen angefragt für
dieses Produkt waren 150.000 € für 10 %
Firmenanteile 450.000 haben sie bekommen
mussten allerdings 20% abgeben wodurch
sich ein Firmenwert von 750.000 € ergibt
bekommen haben sie das Geld von Ralf
Dümmel und Carsten Maschmeyer und das
ist das Produkt bzw die Produkte diese
beiden Produkte sind nämlich dafür da
Fahrradfahrern eine einfache und sichere
Möglichkeit zu geben im Dunkeln gesehen
zu werden und wirklich blinken zu können
was ziemlich cool ist ich habe gerade
schon gesagt
auch gefällt mir gut dass die beiden
Geräte mit usb-c geladen werden ist aber
im Zweifelsfall auch so ein bisschen zu
erwarten weil das Produkt 199 Euro
kostet und ich habe direkt einen
Kritikpunkt den ich aber später
anbringen möchte im Prinzip werden diese
beiden Gerätschaften um den Arm
geschnallt über die Kleidung gut
sichtbar und dann über Gestensteuerung
den Arm ohne die Hand vom Lenkrad
wegnehmen zu müssen einmal so nach oben
und das Blinken anzuzeigen genau das
testen wir jetzt wir wollen los mit
einem Affenzahn Paris Tour 2.0 zack zack
zack zack zack hier kommt die erste
Abbiegung
[Musik]
alles krass es wirklich gut auch bei
schnellem fahren wenn ich mich so bewege
gehen die Blinker nicht an also ich kann
mich schon bewegen ohne dass der Blinker
angeht und nicht eine falsche Richtung
Anzeige
linker an
und Meter machen aber neben dem normalen
Modus in dem der Flasher nicht
durchgängig leuchtet sondern nur wenn
man blinken möchte gibt es noch einige
andere Modi die man nach Belieben wählen
kann fazit ich finde es ziemlich geil es
funktioniert es hat einen stolzen Preis
aber der ist auf jeden Fall wert wenn es
um die eigene Sicherheit geht eine Idee
hätte ich aber die ist für mich noch ein
bisschen cooler machen will die
Möglichkeit die beiden Dinger an die
Arme zu machen ist super weil wir so
anzeigen können wo wir hinfahren wollen
auf der anderen Seite müssen wir dafür
extra Produkte mitnehmen und mir würde
es aber glaube ich als Fahrradfahrer
darum gehen die Sachen die ich mitnehmen
muss auf ein Minimum zu reduzieren ein
Helm der also den Fleischer eingebaut
hat und über eine leichte Kopfbewegung
genau diese Richtungswechsel anzeigen
kann wäre für mich ein noch viel
geileres Produkt Produkt Nummer 4 namens
weiß womit wir offiziell in den oberen
50% des fundings angekommen sind
flüssige Gewürze auf Kokosöl Basis vom
Gründer oder von den Gründern angefragt
waren 150.000 € für 20% bekommen haben
sie 150.000 € für 20 Prozent und wir
schauen ob sie halten was sie
versprechen was sie versprechen
natürliche Inhaltsstoffe vegan auf
Kokosöl Basis und ziemlich nice für die
Erklärung und sie aber mein Rechner
rausholen wie funktioniert das genau Öl
und Geschmacksträger werden aus den
Gewürzen herausgelöst das Extrakt wird
dann mit wasserlöslichen und
geschmacksneutralen Kokosöl vermischt
dadurch bleiben Geschmack Nährstoffe und
Aromen der flüssigen Gewürze erhalten
ziemlich cool sogar und Sternekoch
alexander Herrmann empfohlen und wir
haben mexikanische Art Knoblauch
asiatische Art indische Art und
italienische Art die große Frage kann es
traditionelle Gewürze ablösen und hält
das was verspricht das alles nehmen wir
unter die Lupe aber nicht mit mir als
line sondern in dem absoluten Profi Max
der 20 m entfernt in unserer Küche auf
uns wartet ich habe euch angelogen wir
sind nicht in der Küche sondern auf
einem Dreh und deswegen testen wir das
jetzt mit Happy Slice der neuen Pizza
von knossum trymacs wir hatten das ganze
schon mit Max gemeinsam getestet die
Details aber abgekackt also jetzt die
Pizza einmal so und dann mit plus
hammer geil richtig gut das einzige was
ist jetzt noch besser machen könnte
obwohl es schon sehr vollmundigen
Geschmack hat ist gewürzextrakt auf Öl
Basis Grip
ich muss sagen ich finde das in
flüssiger Form übelst geil es ist übelst
gut zu mischen es ist wenn man komplett
Kranke Geschmacksexplosion haben will
auch mega geil sich ein zwei Tropfen auf
so einen Happen drauf zu machen für eine
schnelle Zubereitung für Leute die
weniger Zeit haben ist das perfekt und
ich finde das hammergeil also vermutlich
wenn ihr Profi Kochzeit greift der Satz
Schuster bleibt bei deinen Leisten wenn
ihr so seid wie ich dann geil Option und
happy übrigens auch das nächste Produkt
nennt sich Sunny back von Gründer Stefan
ponsold und Philips Lapa sie wollten
200.000 € für 10 %, was sind Firmenwert
von 2 Millionen Euro ergeben hätte Ralf
Dümmel hätte ihn 200.000 € für 20 %
gegeben was einen Firmenwert von einer
Million Euro macht der Deal ist aber
leider nach der Sendung geplatzt ob das
Produkt hält was es verspricht und ob es
nicht doch schlauer verreifte mir
gewesen wäre den Deal durchzuziehen
schauen wir uns jetzt an von hier geht
dann Adapter raus auf USB und da kann
man dran stecken was man will in meinem
Fall jetzt ein Handy Ladekabel das
funktioniert was mir aber wirklich als
erstes aufgefallen ist vor allem als ich
den Rucksack angezogen habe der Rucksack
an sich ist keine besonders gute
Qualität ich bin wirklich großer
Rucksack Liebhaber und habe zwei Modelle
auf die ich 100% vertraue da kein
helipro und f-stop Tilopa ich bin
wirklich bei Rucksäcken gegen dich ein
bisschen ab aber die müssen finde ich
funktionieren klar was kann man erwarten
bei 100 €, aber mit ein paar Euro mehr
die man ausgibt landet man schon bei
einem da kein Heli Pro oder bei anderen
sehr sehr guten Rucksäcken an sich
funktioniert das Produkt aber wunderbar
also das Solarpanel tut was soll das
lädt unser Handy ein nächster kleiner
negativer Punkt am Rucksack es gibt
keine direkte Verbindung in den Rucksack
was ich ziemlich doof finde weil
natürlich kann es sein dass man im
Rucksack Dinge laden möchte und dafür
gibt es keinen Eingang fürs Kabel Sunny
back hat aber unheimlich viele
verschiedene Produkte also möchte man
mehr Leistung gibt es größere
Solarpanels möchte man mehr Leistung
speichern gibt es große wirklich
wirklich große powerbanks die ich
tatsächlich selber im Einsatz habe also
Feedback macht richtig gute Produkte
dieser Rucksack ist jetzt vielleicht
nicht eine absolute zehn von zehn aber
die Produkte funktionieren die
Solarpanels funktionieren und vor allem
die Power Stations sind ein absoluter
Traum und für mich das eigentliche
mainprodukt von sunbeck zurück zu den
Massage Dingern nee triggerdingern was
soll ich sagen als jemand der
tatsächlich ehrliche Probleme mit dem
Rücken und allgemein mit seinem Körper
hat weil er nicht genug Sport macht zu
lange am Schreibtisch sitzt und so
weiter sind diese Dinger hier ein
absoluter Segen ich war ja schon Heavy
User von den ganzen blackrollprodukten
das hier ist aber noch mal eine Stufe
krasser man kann noch mal eine Stufe
genauer die Sachen behandeln die
tatsächlich weh tun und für mich ist das
ein absolutes Produkt es ist einfach es
tut was es soll klar es ist teuer aber
das bin ich von genau solche Produkten
schon gewohnt ich finde die Produkte
richtig geil und ich denke ich werde sie
weiter benutzen mit Produkt Nummer 6
kommen jetzt schon wirklich in den hohen
Pfannen Bereich und das auch mit einem
guten Grund verschiedene Bereiche sind
Frieden gut bezahlt und wir gehen mit
dem nächsten Produkt in den Finanzsektor
dass sich pago-pace nimmt angefragt
waren 200.000 Euro für zehn Prozent was
eine Firmenwert von 2 Millionen gemacht
hätte bekommen haben sie die 200.000
Euro für 15% Anteile an Ihrem
Unternehmen was empfehlen Wert von einer
Million 333.000 und 333 Euro macht
bekommen haben sie die Kohle von Carsten
Maschmeyer das hier ist das Packaging
wir mussten das schon aufmachen wir
haben es ein bisschen vorbereitet denn
bevor man den eigentlichen Ring bekommt
schickt Parco pace hier so ein Raster
bei dem man seine verschiedenen
Ringgrößen testen kann denn es handelt
sich um einen nfc-ring mit dem eine
Bezahlung kontaktlos ohne Verbindung zum
Handy dauerhaft möglich ist ohne dass
der Regen geladen werden muss ohne dass
er irgendeine Verbindung braucht was
ziemlich cool ist eine Sache die mir
direkt auffällt wir konnten auswählen
zwischen weiß schwarz und so weiter was
ist nicht gibt ist Gold oder Silber auch
nicht farbig also Keramik eingefärbt
oder so ich kann mir vorstellen dass
solche metallischen Materialien Probleme
machen mit dem NFC Signal aber eine
Färbung in die Richtung wäre schon
ziemlich cool bei Gold und Silber
einfach die Farben sind die regelmäßig
am meisten getragen werden weiß sieht
man relativ selten wäre jetzt
tatsächlich auch nichts für das ich mich
einfach so entscheiden würde jetzt
kommen wir aber zum entscheidenden Teil
der Anleitung und der Einrichtung es ist
ein extra Konto bei curve soweit ich
weiß erforderlich wir haben das ganze
schon bisschen vorbereitet damit ein
bisschen schneller geht Aktivierung
erforderlich ihr Bezahlkarte wurde mit
einem Keramik pago-preis verbunden aber
deine wearable muss noch aktiviert
werden lade die für Desmo App runter und
Scanner den QR Code um den
Aktivierungsprozess zu starten Problem
jetzt gerade wir sind in der App wir
connecten hier alles über diese fedesmo
App aber der Aktivierungscode per SMS
kommt und kommt einfach nicht an Leo
kontaktiert jetzt gerade hier den
Support das ist direkt mal ein
entspannter Minuspunkt für den
Registrierung Prozent das hat
tatsächlich funktioniert wir konnten
alles einrichten es war etwas trage ich
und das wird garantiert in die Bewertung
mit eingehen aber jetzt geht es um die
Funktionalität ich ziehe mir den Ring an
es fühlt sich etwas komisch an und ich
finde immer noch dass es zu auffällig
ist
[Musik]
hallo schön guten Tag ich würde das
gerne mit diesem Ring bezahlen
ich bedanke mich vielmals für diesen
einfachen Bezahlvorgang danke tschüss ja
das ist ja unglaublich also es
tatsächlich ganz geil es funktioniert
wie eine Kreditkarte ich glaube vor zwei
Jahren wo die Sendung ungefähr
ausgestrahlt wurde war der flashende
Effekt noch mal ein bisschen krasser
einfach weil die Leute noch weniger
Kontakt mit kontaktlosem bezahlen hatten
mittlerweile weiß jeder das funktioniert
Apple pay ist da und so weiter aber
dieses Produkt funktioniert auch ich
trage keine Ringe ich sehe mich nicht
mit diesem Ring und für die Bewertung
kommt natürlich noch der
Registrierungsprozess dazu der so
mittelmäßig war also für mich ist es ein
winning Produkt eine coole Idee für eine
bestimmte Käuferschaft mit einem
schlechten Registrierung Prozess also
ungefähr so angekommen bei Produkt
Nummer 7 dem Produkt mit dem größten
funding in kleinen Format und kleiner
Verpackung der nasira von sixx live pro
angefragt waren 250.000 € für 20%
bekommen hat der Gründer tatsächlich
diese 250.000 € für 20%, das in vielen
Wert von 1,25 Millionen Euro macht Ralf
Dümmel hat investiert und das hier soll
die All-in-One-Lösung für das Rasieren
von Nasenhaaren sein ohne die
Schleimhäute zu belasten ohne irgendwas
ans Laden hängen zu müssen ohne sich
Kaltwachs in die Nase stecken zu müssen
eine einfache Möglichkeit auf 8 cm
perfekt fürs Reisen um die Nasenhaare zu
rasieren um ehrlich zu sein ich benutze
keinen nasenhaarrasierer dass der Grund
warum mir auch hin und wieder meine Nase
sieht deswegen ist es perfekt um das
jetzt ausprobieren zu können sieht
wirklich sehr einfach aus so einfach wie
genial das sind ja im Prinzip meine
Lieblingsprodukte tatsächlich wirkt das
hier so als wären die Klingen sogar
austauschbar im Prinzip super einfach
man soll einmal die Nasenlöcher
anfeuchten dann nimmt man dieses Ding
dreht es in Richtung vom Pfeil und das
soll im Prinzip die gesamte Magie sein
also das muss man schon sagen unangenehm
was nicht ich habe mich nicht
geschnitten Handhabung zehn von zehn
super easy und das hier ist jetzt das
Ergebnis vorher nachher soll ich sagen
das Produkt funktioniert 11,99 € ist ein
wirklich fairer Preis kann mehrmals
benutzt werden perfekt um zu reisen auch
mit dem Flugzeug also es ist wirklich
top Kaufempfehlung und damit auch das
Ende des Videos vergesslich das Video zu
liken den Kanal zu abonnieren dann sehen
wir uns in den nächsten Tagen wieder
macht's gut
[Musik]